c'est le futur avion de combat européen
tout un système connecté avec notamment
plusieurs drones pour la start-up jcp
connect basée à rennes ce projet est une
opportunité pour créer une collaboration
avec airbus
cette société de 12 salariés est
spécialisée dans la conception de
logiciels destinés aux drones
on s'occupe de ce type de communication
le réseau de drones à deux objectifs
c'est effectivement de transmettre les
données venant capteurs qui peuvent être
des captures vidéos ou d'autres types de
capteurs avec une fiabilité qui est
bonne mais également d'assurer la
sécurité parce que effectivement ce type
de réseau peut être vulnérable à deux
types d' attaque d'une part une attaque
venant d'un capteur onf au capteur ou
une attaque venant dans drôles comme jcp
connect ils sont une cinquantaine de
start up à présenter leurs activités aux
collaborateurs d'airbus cybersécurité
intelligence artificielle spatiale
plusieurs secteurs d'innovation ouvert à
des partenariats par le groupe
aéronautique avec linster en fait si une
start up qui a développé une imprimante
3d qui nous intéresse beaucoup
parce qu'elle est capable d'utiliser un
certain nombre de matériaux basée à
bayonne linster a été créé en 2015 elle
propose des imprimantes 3d destinés à la
production ou à la conception de
prototypes
cette pièce elle a été à aller à dire en
étude pour il représente une application
de protection de câbles électriques pour
un avion et il ya des spécificités
matière à respecter pour que la pièce
puisse résister en des hydrocarbures à
des huiles moteurs à du kérosène
déjà partenaire d'airbus à toulouse elle
souhaite développer une collaboration
avec l'activité defence and space sur un
sujet confidentiel